Matthews got it back too fast four man
rush Stafford looks looks rose d+ I got
[Applause]
we go
[Applause]
Matthew Stafford the long touchdown pass
to Marvin Hall on Sunday part of the
lines victory over the New York chance
the Lions had three games in a row that
they lost they could have won each one
of them they could be not just in the
thick of things they could be one of the
best teams in the NFC right now if they
had a few things follow their way
Matthew Stafford has been one of the
best quarterbacks in the NFL for most of
his career but because the team around
him has never been all that great he
doesn't get the same consideration he's
not viewed as a franchise quarterback
even though he's definitely paid like
one and big cat you're your take from
the ultra popular podcast pardon my take
is that Matthew Stafford is a dark-horse
MVP candidate you have the floor yes I'm
gonna give credit to Matt Stafford
Matthew Stafford now let me let me just
set the table here and say I know that
he's not gonna win the MVP that's not
what this is it's gonna go to Russell
Wilson Aaron Rodgers deshaun Watson guys
who have had that narrative because it's
a narrative award have the narrative and
the team behind them there's the the
other thing I should say Mike is that it
is a quarterback's award right we just
mentioned off air but 2012 is the last
time a non quarterback has won the MVP
so knowing it's a quarterback award and
throwing out all the running backs and
saying it's gonna be just the best
quarterback Matt Stafford should be in
the conversation if you made a list of
five guys he should be in those top five
guys in terms of quarterbacks this
season right now Mike right now down you
see that tied for second well guess what
what that doesn't show is the guys that
are ahead of him and tied with him they
have all played one more game than him
so he hasn't had he had his bye week
Aaron Rodgers hasn't had his bye week
Russell Wilson hasn't had his bye week
deshaun Watson hasn't had his PI week so
Matt Stafford for all intents and
purposes here is leading the league in
touchdown he's limiting his mistakes
he's only got four interceptions his
completion percentages is I think
top-five but more than anything Mike
when we talk about MVP and what you're
doing for your team the team around
Matthew Stafford is a lot less talented
than the team around Russell Wilson and
the team around Sean Watson and the team
around Aaron Rodgers
the Detroit Lions we've known for years
cannot run the ball they just lost carry
on Johnson but they cannot run the ball
you're when you when you look at the
Seahawks and the Texans those are top
ten running teams the Packers just
outside of that Aaron Jones has been
very good for the Packers this year so
Matt Stafford is asked to do more with
less and he has been fantastic this year
again he's not gonna win MVP because the
Lions are probably not gonna be good
enough and because again it is a
narrative award and it feels like we've
anointed whatever the next guy is gonna
be deshaun Watson because of the mahomes
injury but Matt Stafford should be at
least discussed in the MVP race and
should be in that top five dark horse
getting the credit that he deserves to
be the league's MVP see I disagree with
you that's an that it's a narrative
award I think that the formula is very
simple it's typically one of the
quarterbacks from the top two seeds in
either conference if you're the
quarterback of a team that finishes with
the one seed in the AFC or the NFC
you're already going to get serious
consideration and if you're not one of
the quarterbacks for this the teams that
aren't buys you've got to have some
statistical overachievement that just
makes you stand out among the rest
something historic or close to historic
then again that never got Drew Brees the
MVP Offensive Player of the Year yes but
never the MVP typically it goes to
somebody from one of the top teams
unless there is some like Adrian
Peterson the year he almost set the
single-season rushing record that was an
exception typically it's a quarterback
from one of the top teams in either
conference but deshaun Watson and
Russell Wilson aren't gonna be top teams
in their conference I mean I may be the
type of man that may not win it right
it's gonna be Aaron Rodgers then if the
Packers are the 1 seed it's gonna be
Aaron Rodgers but I think the narrative
behind those guys you see the buzz early
I think that's a big part of it when you
start getting the conversation in
September about being an MVP I think
that helps you propel you to being an
MVP that's how a lot of these awards
work it's what's in them like public
conscience here what people are saying
oh that look at that guy he might be MVP
there's articles written about him
people talk about it
so that's kind of my point with the
narrative award that
you have to have the MVP buzz far before
December rolls around and I think that
those three guys all have it mats that
four dozen you're right
did I mean the Lions aren't going to be
good enough but I think he's doing he
making light run no no let's say they
would run the table right they've played
seven games let's say they would go nine
and oh the rest of the way and they'd
finish 12 three and one and they they
they make it to the playoffs and he has
some ridiculous statistical season and
he leads the league in touchdown passes
I mean that there are guys who will come
on later in the year typically what
happens is the narrative locks in early
because the guys playing incredible
football and he continues to play
incredible football but this year
especially you know the Mahatma Holmes
was the guy and then they lose a couple
of games and it opens the door for
Russell Wilson and then mahomes gets
injured and now you know how you can't
miss more than one or two games and not
fall off the map all together because
there's guys who's gonna be played all
16 games I I'm not I'm just I'm telling
you I think there's a chance for
Stafford but he's gonna have to earn it
the back half of the season and going
eight and one or nine and OH is gonna be
a big part of it this was all a trick I
just started the narrative see that's I
started the narrative now it's being
talked about he deserves more credit not
very much not very much after this egg
you get credit you started the narrative
we'll be right back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports